when you're working through this because
the idea we're looking at today is
plotting points points from a table of
values now every point let's just think
back to the things that we know in
quantity on tree every point can be
represented with how many numbers on
another plane how many numbers do we
need to say I say that spot there that
point too we need two numbers right what
are the two numbers yeah yeah you could
give me an example like say that what do
you think that is so I want to give me
like a possible pair of numbers think
this could be Eden ah 24 I think that's
fine maybe in fact you want to just
roughly sketch this on the side of the
Pedro here you have this space space
space in I to calm before now what just
to color for me yeah okay so very let's
look at this one again I need a bit of
help to know whether this is right or
wrong our two numbers one of them is an
X and one's a y which ones which yeah
hold on hold on which is which of these
numbers is the X which is the Hawaiian
yeah [ __ ] the two is there is the X and
the four is why it's just alphabetical
isn't it okay now along with that now
let's look at these axes which one is
which which one is which here Charlie
yeah
very good okay our last piece that we
need is where we start from this is the
most important point on the whole plan
ok now we're ready to talk about love to
color for means what does it mean in all
of this in this setup is tonight yeah
yeah they're coordinates start from the
origin go to along this x-axis so I'm
actually going to draw from stroller I'm
going to draw one too that's how far i
went to the right and then what i do at
this fall yeah yeah so i'm going to
climb up right like this okay so get
meant in fact last one it meant go to
the right and then for upwards are you
happy with that so we remember how this
works okay now if I want to give you a
whole bunch of points I could write 2
comma 4 3 comma 5 0 comma negative on I
keep keep trying this okay but we're
sort of Lana it's a bit of pain having
to write brackets in the commons in that
kind of thing so that's why frequently
you'll see one of these turns your piece
of paper okay this is a table of values
and you can see there are some X's along
the top and some wires along the bottom
okay so what I'm going to do is read off
of this a bunch of points and then draw
where they are okay so have a look at
this time with me the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to read a
vehicle was a me when you talked about
to color for you called Matt something
like that pair of numbers starting with
the seed you remember what it was
coordinates very good we're gonna read
the coordinates that's the pairs of
numbers that's what that Co means right
we're going to read the coordinates of
each point that they're interested in
from the table okay now on your piece of
paper feel please feel free to write all
of this right you can see there's a pair
of numbers one of them is an x1 owns or
why ok so I'm going to kind of translate
from this table into the pair of numbers
right that negative 4 that's the X so it
goes first and then there's the two
that's the way it goes
good okay are you with me you see how
that works I have a look at this next
pair of numbers what set of coordinates
is that anyone yeah very good negative 2
and 0 is perfect and you can keep on
going can you tell me what the other
points are what's the third one turn one
and negative 3 yeah you can see the
number here very good someone told me
the fourth one dash very good and the
last one some does it yeah I bet
fantastic okay so you can see I rain
down on the table because the X and the
wires go down the tables okay sometimes
you'll see a table that's drawn the
other way you can draw this on the side
too if you've got some space there and
you can represent the same numbers just
standing up rather than laying down
right I could have negative 4 and 2
negative 2 and 0 1 negative 3 you get
the idea okay all right very good that's
that's the good step second step is you
need to think pink right look at all of
these points that we've got here up on
the top okay I want to know how big
there's some Cartesian plane right this
set of um set of axes and stuff I want
to know how big I need to make this okay
so I need to know how big this way and
how big this way so I'm going to answer
them one at a time first question I'm
gonna think about is how far left and
right will I need to go right how far
left and right so this is about
horizontal stuff which numbers tell me
about the horizontal vows is it exes or
the wives yeah Renee sure it's the exes
right so look at the X values right if
we have a look at the X values just have
a look at them up here there we go
negative 4 negative 2 15 and 2 right
what's the most negative number you can
see there it's the just shout it out
it's their negative 4 and what's the
most positive number you can see it's
the five right so for instance I don't
need horizontally I don't need an x axis
that goes from negative 100 to 100 cuz
look you've never going to need
those really big numbers does that make
sense okay all right coming back down
what do you think this next doc point
says how far up and down very good and
which values am I looking at up and out
why cuz they're the verticals so now
come back up the top let's look at these
guys here are the Y values that I've
highlighted in pink and again you don't
need to shout out this time but you can
see the lowest value you can see the
highest value you know for instance you
don't need to go from like negative 10
to 10 that's too far you're going to be
wasting a whole lot of space if you do
that does that make sense yeah so we've
thought about it okay good step 3 this
is where you're going to need that ruler
that I was talking about and I'm going
to show you how to do this what you need
to do now is draw the thing you going to
draw is these axes that we've just been
thinking about their science right and
we want to use um a pencil and a ruler
to do that okay sorry not pencil and
ruler a pen and a ruler I'll tell you
why in a second okay a pen and a ruler
I'll fill in that last blank in a minute
I'm just going to go to the next page so
that you can see the way that I do this
ok so pick on your pickup you roll up I
would recommend you go into your book
and do this because most of you will
have a grid which will help you a lot ok
once you got the hang of drawing them
with a grid that you can sort of
graduate to join them without a grid ok
so here's what I'm gonna do with my
ruler really important that I use a
ruler for this right I'm going to draw a
vertical line this is my y-axis oops and
I'm going to draw a horizontal line this
is my x-axis ok now it's really
important that I notice these axes right
do they just stopped up the top and the
bottom is that like the highest if you
go they can keep going right in fact
they can keep going forever if you got
younger sibling so you can ask play a
fun game with them not fun for them fun
for you you know what's the biggest
number you can think of and they'll be
like oh a hundred hundreds a very common
one and you're like I can
a bit of a bigger one they're like no
you can't you say 101 and then they're
like don't learn and you weren't they'll
be like a million and you're like
million of one right you can keep
playing this game okay so my point is
after you've finished torturing your
younger sibling these axes the numbers
they go on forever and go on forever
right so that's why we've got arrows
there yeah try playing the game without
is nothing it works better with younger
sons okay so you can see my axes please
note this right they go on forever so
that's why there are errors okay okay so
I've drawn the axes and if you come back
over here we're in step 3 right and what
I've just drawn there don't forget the
arrows don't forget the arrows okay all
right step 4 we're almost there these
two axes you've drawn right there could
be anything who knows what these things
are so we need to say what they are
we're going to not just draw them we're
going to label them okay now I there's
three important things to label first
there's the axes themselves remember one
of them is an X and ones of why in
addition to the axis of what they're
called what's the most important point
on the whole another plane it's the
origin right 00 so label the origin and
last thing you need is a scale an
appropriate scale one that makes sense
don't go off to 100 if the numbers are
all these little like 0 1 2 3 4 5 make
an appropriate so now come back to your
page your book okay again in pen right
I'm going to marquee and there's my
x-axis there's my y-axis what was the
most important point again the origin
there it is okay in fact I'm going to
draw a bit smaller and then we need a
scale then we use scale okay now when we
had a look at those numbers at that
table just look at the top of your page
right those tables indicate to me I
think if we go from negative 5 25
and negative 5 25 I think that'll catch
all the numbers that we did do do I have
any numbers bigger that that'll be fine
right okay let's do it so I'm going to
climb up this axis like this you can see
I've made one two three four five marks
okay so they go up the page that looks
good I could draw more but I don't need
more what about the bottom half you
looked at this violet at these other
regions what's going to happen yeah
fantastic negative 1 negative 2 negative
3 and so on all the way down wonderful
ok that was the y axis the vertical one
I need the x axis too so I'm going to
put in the same kinds of marks 1 2 etc
and of course to the left numbers are
getting negative ok now i will point out
we've drawn a whole lot of numbers we
don't actually need all of these so
later on we're going to talk about like
when do you write like just some of them
and not all of them but for now let's
make it complete ok so this is what my
set of actions looks like I hope yours
looks pretty similar we're finally on
this last step do you remember we took
our table and we read off at the
coordinates ok so we're going to take
those coordinates and we're going to
plot them we're going to plot the points
you'll also hear this called graphy
because graphene just means draw me a
picture and sometimes in fact quite
often you get asked to join them up and
you got a bunch of points John you don't
connect the dots you don't always so
that's why I've said join them if
relevant ok look carefully what the
questions asking you to do